initiation gratuite à l'équitation grâce
au dispositif vers les yvelines
c'est un dimanche par an à la base de
loisirs de trappe comme ma fille a fait
de l'âne sur les pas de stevenson
l'année dernière on a marché dans les
cévennes et qu'elle a tout ça on va
faire du dromadaire je me suis dit
contre les deux c'était bien de refaire
du cheval après la préparation des
chevaux et poneys les cavaliers en herbe
règle les derniers détails avec la
monitrice est ce que la longueur la vous
convient c'est un peu court non ça va
quelques petits tours de carrière et
c'est parti pour une balade de 45
minutes
et sinon on fera que du pas justement
pour limiter des risques et on va
prendre des chemins relativement balisée
que les chevaux connaissent et qui vont
permettre d'avoir des chevaux calmes et
disponible déclaré profite pas seulement
du poney mais aussi du paysage autour
justement derrière les arbres nos
apprentis cavalière découvre les
structures ludiques de la base de
loisirs sans cantine oise l'occasion
pour les monitrices de se transformer un
temps en guide les prochaines randonnées
équestres collective avec le centre se
font sur réservation
quand tu es maximum 30 euros pour une
heure trente d'activité